innovative insightful revolutionary very
very powerful intense it blows your mind
and widens your horizons Stanford ignite
is a certificate in innovation and
entrepreneurship it's a program that
provides two main things to students we
give exposure to basic business
fundamentals operations marketing
finance and then we also match our
students into teams and they work for
the duration of the program on a project
and at the end of the program they pitch
that idea to panels of VCS entrepreneurs
and industry experts I mean all the
content all the projects are around
giving them the skills so they can start
with with an innovation but end with
with a viable in fact for adventure
gives us these frameworks that help us
with design thinking you know making a
business model much more robust I think
we're really lucky to have had the best
best faculty in the world in management
education coming down to Bangalore it is
not physically then via video
conferencing and they were able to
accommodate all that questions and give
really personal attention to every
student the interactive nature of the
class whether it was being held from
Palo Alto or whether it was faculty
taking it here on site in bangalore
Stanford ignite usually made that
seamless the classroom is filled with
diverse personalities from legal
departments from medical sciences or as
I got to know each and every person I
realized everybody had something special
about them so it really did seem like
you know Stanford took a very very
meticulous approach in figuring out who
those people who are and that added a
lot of value I know that these are
people I'm going to be interacting with
very frequently in the near future and
native as well part of the enduring
value of the Stanford ignite program is
that you now belong to a network of
other like-minded very high potential
people imagine being part of this entire
standard family and you know the access
to all these actually feeling people i
think the entire course is absolutely
practical i know for a fact that all the
tools that I've learned here is gonna
keep me free better equipped to work on
that particular idea of mine anybody
who's interested in in a wedding where
they're internally within their own
organization or is aspiring to be an
entrepreneur they're an ideal fit for
this course I think every individual who
wants to kind of unleashes potentials I
was recommended to basically anybody in
any domain who wants to take an idea and
do something with it with the Stanford
ignite program our approach is to find
extraordinary people who want to do
extraordinary things and we equip them
with a skill set that they need to go
off and launch themselves into careers
of impact and meaning
you